on Prime crime when I got the call that
Carl passed away my instinctive thought
was it's got to be her a Savage murder
it was just shock and dismay we couldn't
believe what was going on an elusive
killer I find her to be incredibly
manipulative and a call for justice and
you put the gun 12 to 24 in from his
head and pulled the trigger
correct
[Music]
hey there everybody I'm Jessie Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most
high-profile and memorable True Crime
cases now this story is about how
authorities were trying to catch a
killer for years and when they finally
did you're never going to believe what
they
heard March 12th 2007 may have been a
normal day for many people but but for
the family of Air Force Major Carl herig
this was the start of a nightmare after
herig didn't report to work law
enforcement go to his home in Newton
Falls Ohio and discover his dead body it
was just shock and dismay we couldn't
believe what was going on authorities
would conclude that Carl had been shot
three times his body found at the bottom
of a stairwell and covered with a tarp
but there was something missing from the
house or rather someone and she wasn't
around it was very easy to put two and
two together it was very obvious what
happened Claudia Herod Carl's wife was
nowhere to be found investigators would
soon find out that their main suspect
was not only no longer in Ohio she
wasn't even in the US instead she had
left for her native country of Brazil
days earlier when I got the call that
Carl passed away my instinctive thought
was it's got to be her while some who
knew the couple sense something might be
off Carl's friend Christa Bridges would
tell authorities an eerie story about
Claudia the year prior to Carl's death
Bridges said Claudia made this comment
about Carl at a bachelorette party I was
eating and then Claudia just leaned over
and said if he ever left me I'd kill him
authorities learned that Claud had
purchased a gun days before the shooting
took out money from the bank and made a
quick getaway but with Claudia now in
Brazil authorities and her's loved ones
faced a major legal obstacle Brazil does
not normally extradite to the US for
their own citizens he was in fact born
in Brazil this was a very difficult
process from the beginning they were not
going to extradite Claudia herig and
that's when we started talking with the
local Congressman Tim Ryan did a really
good job of creating publicity around
this case and then when I started the
Facebook page Justice For Carl harig I
had a u an international audience and
many people from Brazil supported our
efforts the fight by politicians lawyers
and Carl supporters to get Claudia back
to the States would last over 10
years but then a breakthrough the
Brazilian government revokes Claudia's
citizenship in 2013 and in 2018 she's
officially extradited back to America
interestingly she had relinquished her
Brazilian citizenship in exchange for an
American citizenship it was touch and go
all along I was ecstatic you know now we
finally had a chance to uh present the
case when herig is finally arrested this
is where things take a different turn so
you're willing to
talk and you're sure
because I have nothing to I believe that
Claudia thought that she could outsmart
everyone she obviously had a lot of time
to think through her answers to almost
every single question the one thing she
didn't lack was answered her Begins by
explaining how she met Carl online and
they married in 2005 but this
relationship at least according to her
was very
strange he won our crazy
lifestyle both doing all kinds
of perverted stuff men women everything
he forced me to play dead he would only
have an orgasm if I played dead Eric
said the behavior got worse had box with
things that he doed me with
robes
um call the
um the Whip and he made me walk around
me in the house on the high hills all
the time doesn't matter how cold it was
I thought that that description was
problematic it was when people are
telling lies that they go a few steps
too far and she really laid it on heavy
with Kink shaming essentially I think
number one to engender sympathy and
number two to smear him to make him look
like he deserved it and that she was
being abused her even blamed Carl's
alleged mistreatment for multiple
miscarriages and I got SI
after a few days my body just couldn't
take it anymore in terms of blaming him
for the miscarriages that also is
bizarre as far as I know there was no
medical proof of that about 2006 I got
PR again and again he did the same thing
to me same toward same it would be
totally uncharacteristic for those kinds
of
things those things if valid should have
been brought up ahead of time har
explained that her situation became so
dire particularly when she became
pregnant for a third time that she
eventually decided to commit suicide I'm
not going to have an
abortion there's nothing that's going to
make me have an abortion and he doesn't
want to tr what am I going to do kill
myself when you look at some of the
behaviors that she's exhibited in you do
see um especially some traits of uh
borderline personality disorder a lot of
suicidal gestures a lot of threats for
suicide attempts this is all really
consistent with what we're saying with
her coming up next was suicide really
claud's plan or rather murder my plan
was never not for one single minute to
kill anybody of swear to God there was
enough for a single minute I thought
[Music]
about that shows his character all the
things that he did to me how he screamed
at me how he cursed at me how he abused
me after an over 10year legal and
political battle in 2018 Claudia herig
is extradited from Brazil back to the
United States for the murder of her
husband Carl herig who was found shot to
death in his home back in
2007 however when Claudia decides to
speak with investigators on her Return
To America she accuses Carl of
physically and emotionally abusing her
which led her to want to commit suicide
but listen carefully to her plan the
best way of committing suicide was with
the gun but the downside of killing
yourself with a gun is that it has a
recoil that most people that try to kill
themselves they they they they lose part
of their face but they don't die yet
herig apparently had a solution what I
do I went to the gun gun gun uh store I
asked for a gun that was small enough
for my hands I went to a a a
uhing
obviously not only that but harg also
allegedly built a homemade Contraption
to shoot
herself that
hole to
be right here right here I do not
believe that her plan was to kill
herself she purchased a weapon that had
laser sights and then she went and
practiced it afraid of some Phantom
recoil and then she also con built a box
that she could steady the barrel of the
gun in order to shoot more accurately
that is not something that you typically
or ever see in the case of suicide
battered wife syndrome is really just
kind of a subset of PTSD a person uh
believes that they are an extreme danger
and can't leave that's really not been
the case in this relationship there were
plenty of times where she was left alone
where she had opportunities to leave and
that just didn't
happen let's move to the day of the
shooting Claudia claimed she was
pregnant for a third time and got into a
heated argument with Carl over whether
to have the child at one point he
decides to take a shower and that's when
she decides to act I something very
shocking for you to to to shake him up
so when he opened the door and see me
with a gun he saw me with a gun to my
head he would have no no reaction he
would stare keep star and he said um
that's a very uh uh good idea go to the
basement to do that because you're going
to Splash my my paintings you're going
to Splash blood all over my
paintings and I got very Ang
if he had said
that I would be dead he would be
alive what happens next well what
happened next because I got very angry
and I got up real fast and shocked I
don't think that this is a snap I think
that that had been carefully contrived
over years of planning to explain away
what would otherwise looks like a cold
premeditated murder the act of shooting
somebody the act of killing somebody
takes a lot of steps and it takes a lot
of desensitization that is not normal
for most people I don't think she
snapped it's what Claudia did after the
shooting though that really cast doubt
on this attempted suicide unintentional
killing Theory first she said she wanted
to shoot herself but didn't realize she
didn't have any bullets left I the TR
nothing
happened
Bulls happened then she calls her family
who convinces her to escape and they
said that um Ohio had a death penalty
she goes to the bank to drain out an
account I had 1300 in the bank account
if I clean it up they will know that I
killed my husband I was paranoid so I
only got a th000 and like 300 in the
bank and before she leaves she decides
to cover up Carl's body I want to have
time to to find so I put a cover over
him in the
letter
um uh in case somebody came to the
window they would not see his body so
would have time to to take an get out of
country to get out of the
country all this was done in very quick
succession after the shooting which
leads you to believe that she was
fleeing and flee
can be used as a fact to evidence guilt
if you are someone who behaved in a rage
and you felt Contrition and it was a big
mistake that was predicated upon years
of abuse which is her claim you wouldn't
necessarily run I find her to be
incredibly manipulative I I think this
is what she does is she likes to take
control of situations and um she's
hopeful that with her charm and her
being playful that she may be able to
get out of
this okay I dead inside it's one thing
for law enforcement to not believe that
Claudia was an abused woman who snapped
but what about a
jury I did this I killed Carl and I'm
about to kill myself stay with
[Music]
us do you know where that first shot hit
him no I I actually uh I was just suing
after her extradition back to the United
States Claudia herig is arrested and
charged with the murder of her husband
Air Force Major Carl herig during her
2019 trial the prosecution attempted to
show that she planned to shoot and kill
her husband while her defense team
argued this was a spontaneous act fueled
by years of alleged abuse and Carl's
indifference towards his wife's life and
she shot him because of her moment of
weakness 30 days after she's attempted
suicide when she wants to have a
conversation with him he tells her go
ahead kill yourself moment of weakness
is is just it is a term of art but it's
something that is a basically a heat of
passion defense that you are so enraged
that in that moment of weakened State
you act out upon those feelings that is
theoretically possible from the
statement that she claims her husband
made well there was no one better than
Claudia herself to tell her side of the
story um did you plan to kill caror
never never never for second yet it was
when the prosecution cross-examined
herig that the fireworks really began
before you shot Carl herck you were
upset that he had an engagement party
for you at Puttin Bay correct I thought
that was very weird that was a sign that
some yes or no I'm not asking for an
explanation all I want to know is yes
yes or no before you shot him you were
upset that you had an that he had an
engagement party for you at puton Bay
before you shot him were you upset that
he picked out the clothes you
wore I didn't realize at the time that
yes or no all I want to know is yes or
no what your not understand the question
we're getting to the point you asking
can you answer the questions and not
argue with me please Carl Herod cannot
come in here and explain
any of these situations that you
testified to correct yes he came through
the voice no he can't can Carl Harry
come in this courtroom and testify no
okay thank you her behavior on the stand
is in complete contrast to her behavior
during her interrogation it's almost
like she realizes that she's got caught
and she's lost the power and now she's
angry like you men and women they can
flirt but I never had anything with him
and I have no reason to hide that right
so he he he indicated to you is that a
crime I'm I asked the questions here oh
I'm sorry one way the prosecution tried
to show this was a murder was the actual
gunshot wounds themselves you shot and
killed Carl Herod by putting not one not
two but three shots into his body
correct yes all right and you put the
gun 12 to 24 in from his head and pulled
the trigger correct
probably probably well did somebody else
break into the house and shoot him too
even the crime scene the prosecution
used to show proof of Prior calculation
and design because according to her she
had shot him one time and believed that
he was was dead upon that first shot but
evidence shows and and she did admit
that she later shot at him at close
range additionally and made sure
essentially that he was
dead we the jury in case duly impanel
and sworn or affirm find the defendant
Claudia C her guilty of aggravated
murder as she stands charged in the
first count of the
indictment I was pleased with the guilty
verdict because I think it was the right
decision all of her her planning and
preparation was went was for not
essentially they realized that she was
not telling the truth we completed the
mission and we got Justice For Carl for
his his family for his friends for all
of the people that knew and loved
him you may think Claudia herro will
never step out of prison for the rest of
her life but is that actually the case
more when we
[Music]
return before you shot him were you
upset that you had had these
miscarriages I'm not understanding
question okay let's would before when
five minutes one day I'm not
understanding the question Claudia herig
the woman who executed her husband Carl
her In Cold Blood and then fled the
country for over 10 years was finally
arrested charged and convicted of murder
at her sentencing we heard the moving
Victim Impact statements from Carl's
family I want to list every moment that
it has hurt me the dad's gone I want to
talk about my beautiful kids he never
met I want to talk about grief and
missed opportunities but I would never
be able to stop the loss of my brothers
beyond
words the fact Claudia so arrogantly
fled to a foreign country after killing
my brother has been both heartbreaking
and frustrating knowing Claudia
selfishly went on with a normal life
starting a business and getting
remarried as if nothing had happened is
difficult for me to comprehend people
that have the ability to essentially
live double
lives or commit an act like this and
then move on to something means that
they're really good at
compartmentalizing so this is something
that you'll see you know in these
cold-hearted psychopath but it's also a
trait that's pretty characteristic in a
lot of personality disorders we are here
today for the long awaited culmination
of the worst possible circumstances
contemplated in our criminal system
judge Logan sentenced that then 5
4-year-old to life in prison but with
the possibility of parole after 28 years
as part of the extradition agreement
between the United States and Brazil
Herod couldn't be sentenced to death nor
a term of imprisonment of over 30
years I think that that deal would never
have been strucken unless it was
absolutely mandatory and it was here I
don't think that the US would ever have
their hands on her if they hadn't made
that deal and of course they will honor
that deal I don't think that will ever
be obviously considered for parole until
those 28 years are up but even then
parole can be denied indefinitely so
it'll be interesting to see how the
parole board revisits this issue in 28
years as for herig the woman who said
she didn't care what happened to her her
actions would say otherwise in a legal
letter after the trial she complains
that she's a victim of gross misconduct
and blames everyone for her current
predicament including the government and
her own Tri trial attorney what it seems
like is she's adopted this victim
mentality hoping that others will
believe her to either gain sympathy or
assuage her guilt she also has infered
too well legally her appeal has since
been denied and conviction upheld the
court of appeals found that there was
sufficient evidence to show prior
calculation in design and Essen
essentially they were able to show that
the jury's verdict was based upon sound
evidence in the end it was the memory of
Carl herig that led to the eventual
capture of his killer and it's that
memory that will live on in those who
knew
it he was a good friend I really enjoyed
flying with him he was a great guy a
great pilot he was a flight
instructor and he was just a joy to be
around it is truly a tragedy that we
have had to lose him at such
a young age and
Carl was one of the best he truly
was Claudia herig is just one of those
defendants that gives you the chills and
I got to tell you when she said she was
dead inside she might be right that's
all we have for you here on Prime crime
leave us your comments on Instagram and
Twitter with the hashtag Prime crime as
always thank you for joining us and
until next time be
safe on Prime crime and you pick the
ones that you think you're going to kill
high that the story of one of America's
most infamous murderers because he did
this same Mo over and over again he got
very good at his own words on the
killings did you have any conversation
with her my mind was on killing her and
hear from the people who sat across from
Evil I'll never in my life ever
interview another killer like that that
in my career pluck me another gra
uhhuh how many grapes y all got on
Divine
[Music]
here hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber
and welcome to Prime crime this is where
we do a deeper dive into the most
high-profile and memorable True Crime
cases our next story is about a killer
so renowned we had to dedicate two shows
to this case here is part
one in 1970 a woman is strangled to
death and buried in a shallow grave out
in
Florida from there for the next 35 years
bodies would be found across different
states no
connection no Prime
Suspect it would take decades before
these cases would be solved and finally
connected to one
man she was pretty a light skinned Brown
honey colored K this is Samuel little
also known as Samuel McDow I'm met in in
a night club in New Orleans so I cut off
I took off the exit went and that sure
enough was a road leaking into the
woods and we went in and parked he may
not look like m when investigators began
interviewing him in 2018 in his late 70s
and suffering from health conditions but
the man you're seeing was the most
prolific serial killer in United States
history I gra by the legs and
pull to the water mhm that's the only
one that I ever killed by Drowning
that's just one confession of many that
little provided to authorities after his
capture at the then age of 71 I'll never
in my life ever interview another killer
like that in my career you know you
first see him he's this little old man
in a wheelchair that that will remind me
of a little old man on a porch rocking
in a chair telling you his stories about
his life although his stories were
demented North Little Rock tell me what
that girl looked like oh man I loved her
she was a heavy set big old yellow hair
and had buck
teeth he had a gap between the teeth
that was she too big for me to car
carrier so I just pulled out the car
laid on that trash that was let there
there was no remorse whatsoever it was a
matter of fact I got him to kill he went
into great detail in his crimes oh the
only thing I know in all is that I kill
and that was your intent that was my
intent Sam little ultimately confessed
to 93 murders from 1970 to 2005 that's
more than Ted bun the Zodiac Killer and
the Golden State killer combined we know
of at least 93 women who were murdered
he was not going to stop he actually
told police that he found it sexually
satisfying to rape and kill women in
order to really understand Sam Little's
reign of terror let's first dig into the
killings themselves like many serial
killers Sam little had ano did you ever
shoot any of these girls shoot yeah with
aun
I get no kick out all so everything was
done by uel strangulation did you ever
use like a belt or cloth or anything no
carrots and all that no no ligatures at
all my hands just your hands and without
that I wouldn't want to do
it he would take his hands and he would
put them on their throats and he would
choke them and sometimes he would allow
them to uh revive so he could see the
fear in their eyes before choking out
fun it was squeezing hard enough for the
breath could be cut off and sooner or
later she going to start wan to catch
breath and that's when she tried to pull
my hands off it was too late then mhm
was it exciting to you at the time yes
it was he's a sadistic killer for sure
he wanted to feel like their neck
swallowing and I think his foreplay
basically he would take a lot of them to
eat and they would go eat and swallow
and drink and I think that was his
foreplay that's what got excited was
watching that neck so how was it that
little was able to commit dozens of
rapes and murders without getting caught
the reason Sam little went undetected
for so many years is because of who he
targeted primarily drug addicted women
and sex workers they didn't know who in
the hell was doing it yeah I go back to
the same city sometime and pl pluck me
another gra
uh how many cre yall got on Divine here
Fatman right good one yeah good one so
basically these were women nobody would
miss he knew which women would be not
cared about he knew which women would
not be missed he knew which women would
be susceptible to his advances whether
they're romantic or he was providing
them drugs or providing them alcohol she
was a whole yeah she's old she was
trying to make some money now he knew
which women the lower levels of our
society he could actually lure into his
car to take to a secluded place to
quickly kill them in the dead of night
where nobody could see them and then to
dump their body immediately and get out
a Dodge this is how he got away with it
and I'm not just saying he says it long
you didn't get
in out there with them people that would
be a me immediately missed yeah and
very important to either family or
business or somebody yeah you got pretty
good at knowing which one I'm not going
to go over in the white neighborhood and
pick out little uh young teenage girl or
like the ID do you know and that's how
little got away with it over and over
again and because he did this secret
because he did this same Mo over and
over again he got very good at it coming
up little had spent his life in and out
of prison and had almost been captured
before so what happened I've been lucky
on a numerous
[Music]
times I wanted to be in the vet some
with concealed so she was already dead
in the car yeah okay after Samuel little
is arrested in 2012 on a Narcotics
charge charge investigators realize he's
actually responsible for several Cold
Case killings little would ultimately
confess to 93 murders prior to his
capture though little was a man who had
been arrested almost a hundred 100 times
and only spent a total of 10 years
behind bars so how was he not connected
to these crimes sooner and more
importantly how is he still on the
streets for all this time I was lucky in
Florida mhm I had a dead body in the car
M get J out yes I'm getting
ready BL lights everywhere P these car
and come back behind the building he
seen us far there I jump out the car and
try to act like I'm zipping my pants he
said what's going on over here I said
nothing I said me and my wife just
course damn car looked in that
window with a flashlight I'm tell you
shiny right on the girl she laying there
like she's dead dead yeah and soon as he
was looking in there I said yeah I hear
I got his mind off just n time before he
took a second look and I got away like
that he said well you got to get out of
him I got in the car and off the police
weren't able to put together a strong
case against him because
he himself knew how to get away with
without leaving a lot of evidence I know
cut stay out
burnt
bit no none of that no blood I don't
like blood he would initially strike his
victims in the head and then strangle
them and I think ultimately when you
think about this you're not going to
have any forensic evidence later the
bodies have deteriorated so there were
no markings there were no you couldn't
see knife wounds to Bones you could not
see gunshot bullets there was no
fractures in these bodies
about Pig
farmers and that's how the girl they
found a girl Landing in the field next
to the pig
farm all the SK ate off of the
Rat Sam little would dispose of bodies
in the Everglades he would roll them
down Hills he would put them in densely
forested areas you would like partially
concealed by the
vegetation left for DNA didn't really
start being utilized until the mid 1990s
so he was able to get away with any type
of sexual crimes Alabama did the same
thing I had this black chick up in the
car and
U just got just got through killing them
this mother P of it is sh P nobody ran
the plate or anything like that no so
they didn't put that on he didn't run a
plate nobody no he wasn't looking for no
they found the body man about a month
later even though he had 100 arrests and
served only 10 years prison time I would
blame partially the criminal justice
system because a lot of the cases
against him were dismissed they weren't
followed up with and he was fleeing
constantly he was very transient and
leaving to different areas cities Across
the Nation little had had close calls
before but nothing may have come as
close as to when he was directly tied to
two brutal murders you know we caught
him we believed he was responsible for
Melinda lar murder in 1982 and we know
absolutely he was responsible for
Patricia mount's case now when you're
driving around with Patricia mount in
the front passenger seat did you have
any conversation with her my mind was on
killing her she let me fill the throat I
was caressing it and before I knew it I
uh taged my hands around it and
strangled it after Patricia mount's nude
body was found in that Hayfield hair
fibers and witness testimony linked
little to The Killing and he went on
trial yet once again it was Little's
Lucky Day the jury found him not guilty
as for Melinda lapri a grand jury opted
not to indict him other media has come
to us saying you know if y'all had just
tried him and he was in jail all these
people will be alive and I will tell you
that Melena lpri had been out in the
elements for over three weeks um and if
you saw a picture of of her remains you
would understand there were no evidence
there to gain there were so many things
so many times that uh he was a arrested
for for assaulting women and the women
were ladies of the night they were on
drugs those don't make the best
Witnesses unfortunately a combination of
lack of Hard Evidence issues with
Witnesses and Little's own ways of
covering up his crimes resulted in Weak
cases and him continually striking plea
deals for shorter prison stance Jillian
Lauren a New York Times best-selling
author and someone who spent hours
interviewing Sam little has made it her
mission to be the voice of these victims
because of um the fact that they were
often prostitutes often drug addicts
often women of color um women who were
considered un important or as some cops
used to talk about the women who were
turning up in South Central dead almost
every morning in the 80s um uh nhi no
humans involved but you know it wasn't
just cops he was Tried by jury of his
peers once again it's us who let him go
up next Little's crimee comes to an end
but his story is just beginning I had
desires strong desire to her and kill
her and she played with you a little bit
on the way out there and you killed her
in the car yes I was tried for it you
beat it
too Samuel little who's come to be known
as the most prolific serial killer in
United States history and whose crime
spre span from 1970 to 2005 was able to
elude Justice for years that is until
2012 prosecutors and the police were
never able to actually pin a case on it
until he left his DNA California
actually had a case where they had run
DNA on a c case and they had an
identical case or one that was a similar
Mo and when they tested that DNA the DNA
came back to identical person in Sam
little in September 2012 little was
arrested in a homeless shelter in
Kentucky on an outstanding Cali
California drug charge when he was
extradited back to LA investigators such
as detective mity Roberts were able to
link Little's DNA to material left at
crime scenes in the 1980s I was already
putting together a s little case because
I was working all the cold cases here in
my area in
Mississippi uh Los Angeles Mitch Roberts
called asking do we have anything about
a s l case so she came down interviewed
our witnesses to put together a a method
uh an Mo of the killer Sam little it fit
everything with their
cases in 2014 little was convicted of
the murders of three of his victims
Carol Alfred Audrey Nelson and Guadalupe
aboda but in a way little was also
answering for all the women he had
killed they were human beings and that
they were all totally different they're
You in September 2014 little was
sentenced to to three consecutive life
terms in prison without the possibility
of
parole while little had maintained his
innocence his whole life in 2018 he
finally decided to open up to
investigators what's up man it's so good
to meet you and I'd like to personally
thank you uh for being generous enough
with your time I hope I clear up
some when somebody is incarcerated and
they know they're spending their life in
jail their communication with the
outside world is in essence gone you're
so valuable to Society at this point I
think Worth to these people the
worthless thing to saying that I'm worth
something he opened up because it was
his exit strategy this was Again part of
his overall plan this guy definitely was
ready to talk as soon as he knew he
wasn't going to be receive the death pel
that's the letter that you requested
that our state attorney will not pursue
do the death penalty under any
circumstances now the question became
how do you get little to open up I'd
love to talk to you about Gainesville a
little bit you know that's that's where
I live and work I'm not I'm not a Gator
fan I'm tell you right now you must be
Ohio State right you know what Urban did
for our gators
though for that yeah now you were a USC
fan too or no don't know I can't stand
California but you lived out in
California for a while I believe that
several times going to be Little's
interview for sure wanted to make sure
that myself as a prosecutor was uh going
to be somebody that he wouldn't mind
talking to we knew that he liked the
Cleveland
Browns he's from the Cleveland area
we're from the Cleveland and so that
kind of uh was our cash if you will uh
to be able to build this recort with him
what do you remember about her talking
sh talking
how I did it I talked to him straight I
told him he was a big perv I told him I
didn't agree with him he would say would
you call me a perverted homicidal maniac
and I said well that's like certainly
one of the things I'd call you and he
was just like whatever you're a hoe I
was mostly kind of honest with him
coming up little may have confessed to
numerous murders but how do we know if
he was telling the truth more when we
return
the only that I did was was Str oh
some after serial killer Samuel little
was finally caught in 2012 and convicted
of murdering three women back in the
1980s he decided to confess to more of
his crimes from 1970 to 2005 and that's
when the floodgates opened so I kill a
girl there you know Calla gang they kill
a girl over there in ELC too she also
talked about a uh young lady that she
dumped down a stairwell yeah girl that
was a white girl yeah she was white got
her out of the car pulled her
out jug into the growth back there
little ended up confessing to killing 93
people and would ultimately plead guilty
to several more murders how do we know
though that little was actually telling
the truth I absolutely believe in his
credibility in the stories that he told
he knew everything about my crime in
1982 and then the 1977 remains actually
had a wig on nobody knew that but the
Anthropologist and us and he talks about
she had a wig and he threw it out the
window after he killed our our our very
first victim one other case he was able
to tell what the last item that a lady
had eaten
was basically the carrots out of a salad
and brown coffee and the oopsy report
shows undigested carrots and brown
coffee and then also was from the 70s
but it would have been dark for you so I
don't know how these pictures can really
help you no I don't that must be the
blanket yes the blanket how did you
remember that it was also important what
little said he didn't do we were all
sitting around talking and and the
detective says yeah you know he he
killed mine he drew a picture of her and
I said what year was yours and he said
1998 I said no what Sam look I said he
was not out in 1998 so when they go into
the interview room and this detective is
starting to talk to him about that case
and I'm thinking goly if Sam little
confesses to killing this one that's
going to throw this whole story in in
the in the brink I mean it just none of
it's going to be true and you know he
looked at oh yeah I never her yeah but I
didn't kill that one he said I was going
to kill her he said I came back to kill
her but she was gone I couldn't find her
then I said when Sam could have took
credit for one did not and um and so
they told me he's not out there just
just trying to get numbers he's out
there wan to talk about his cases now we
get a sense of his killings but what
drove Sam little the choking with these
women happened before the sex or during
or right afterwards when did it mostly
happen I choose I picked I choose out
first you pick the ones that you think
you're going to kill no no if one
depends on how I
ne so clearly a lot more to talk about
and in part two of our Sam little story
we're going to get into his background
and psychology why he stopped killing
and also whether little is responsible
for more murders than we know about so
that's all we have for you right now on
Prime crime but leave us your comments
on Instagram and Twitter with the hash
Prime crime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe